[Music]
so this one you'll you'll like you'll
appreciate the players and where this
game comes from soviet championship
but thought it was going to be like
rosman rose in 2022 online right
no this is tallish against the wagon
from 1947.
wow that is
a very russian name
vladimir publisher
yeah yeah and the funny thing is in
russian they they they don't refer to
each other like that they refer to each
other as vladimir pavlovic like they
like the second name yeah so
yeah the page patronemic i think is
wow this looks uh really juicy for away
this position exactly so this is one of
those positions which looks really
really juicy but you have to zero in on
a specific idea and that's where the
difficulty comes from
okay
okay so naturally first instinct is
something involving a rook sacrifice on
e6
um
rookie 6 de6
okay we we we don't really we can't do
anything in terms of d7
right
my other idea is to go that way uh but i
mean queen d7 but this is always an idea
this is
um
one thing like i said i'm very bad at
looking at what black ones i mean it
seems like this is kind of the major
this is an idea yeah rock h5
but what is the why does rook h5 work
because of all this right
and
if there wasn't all this then
what type there's another idea that i'm
hoping is you see
other than rook takes c6 which is what
it's similar to rookie six
yeah yeah um
i'm uh i'm i'm thinking
um
yeah i mean i guess
i guess trying to make f5 work
and then some rook at baruch f5
sacrifice i mean the other idea i had is
quinchi fakuni seven but i think queen
g5 you don't even have to play defense
you can just win
simply queen the e8 yeah exactly
yeah i mean you win the game if you get
f5
which now makes me think
what do you do i mean is it just one of
these moves
okay well if you're making one of these
moves which one
it's definitely not that because then
queen c6 so
it seems like it would be yeah it would
be king f1
correct move is only winning move is
king f1 yeah to prepare f5 that's pretty
it's pretty savage
and this is sort of a good example of i
think targeted thinking you start by
examining the most juicy ideas the ones
that if they if they work basically win
you the game
and
you know once you realize why you know
whether they work if they don't work can
i troubleshoot the problem
and only if all of that doesn't work do
you switch to more
abstract thinking and do you start
considering the sort of second category
of candidate moves like rook a3 or rook
g5 but you should always start but
trying to make the concrete moves work
right
so king f1 very powerful move okay uh
pow semagan queen d8 continue
man that looks
unbelievably depressing
and we should show it to the chat by the
way because a lot of people in your chat
were proposing the immediate f5 why it
doesn't work yeah just gm my chat not
your chat my chat g takes f5 and uh and
you're pinned
yeah rook f5 ef and you can't take back
on f5 you can actually give this check
but uh yeah but even king f8 like a
super right super disrespectful
it doesn't even doesn't even matter
where black goes
yeah
okay so that doesn't quite work but i
feel axis
queen d8
um yeah now
if f5
then
man i i would in a game i would just
play it and hope it wins
so f5 i think black has to take with the
g pawn i don't even see a immediate win
after ef5 but i just rookie seven i mean
it has to be there
rookie seven
queens you don't have to calculate that
because you've only sacked the pawn like
you haven't even sacrificed anything for
that attack
yeah does it calculate it or you don't
have to calculate it no you don't and my
my rule especially in blitz is like if
i've only sacrificed a pawn or even two
pawns and i have a huge attack i'm going
for it without calculating it because
okay i've taken very little risk so if
it doesn't work the game goes on
so f5 gf rook f5 ef5 queen f5 uh if king
g7 um
probably just rook e7 queen e7 de7
very good
rookie 8
queen d7 i mean it it i guess you win
all the pawns so at the end of the day
the queen versus the two rooks is a
winning end game winning end game so
some technique that's how the game went
actually
oh wow so f5 gfrika five takes takes
king g7 rookie seven takes takes rookie
eight queen d7 and then
wow okay and then queen d7 and if king
e8
find
the the most accurate move here and
to me finding the correct move here okay
well you can just use process of
elimination your queen is hanging so you
you have to move it
where should you move it you could play
rook e6 if you really want but
um
where should you move it
you should move it to
i actually really like the correct
sequence here i think it's very
instructive and there's a point to be
made there but first i want you to name
the move
i also want me to name the move
uh
yeah i'm trying to find it i i get i get
kind of lost in these positions because
i don't
i don't know what black is gonna do
like i i don't know what black snacks
move is depending on what my next move
is so i
like i'm debating between queen f4 f3
well um the queen f4 okay so black has
really only one
active idea
which you need to prevent
this is a move that you should
definitely not allow because it creates
concrete counter play against white's
king what move are we talking about
yeah i didn't even realize that like
white doesn't exactly have threats it's
queen of gate queen aid is a very
unpleasant idea you need to prevent it
yeah yeah
i didn't even i just kind of was like ah
i'm trying by the way
queen is the supporting actress again
this this principle comes into play the
best move is the one which keeps the
queen on the least obtrusive intrusive
and obtrusive square
which is what
i guess f3 then f3
yeah a lot of people want queen e4 but
queen e4 is actually a lot less accurate
but gets in the way of rookie's six
ideas exactly it gets in the way of the
rooks queen f3 is best and uh
now again you just sort of need to take
stock of what your attacking ideas are
so for example after black plays um just
a second after black plays rook g7 for
example
the winning line is actually super super
calm like it's just
very straightforward once you identify
the correct idea
so brainstorm what ideas come to mind
just in general
well i just saw another idea which is
kind of interesting but uh just rook f6
comes to mind also like a4 a5
a4a5 comes to mind
but to me there's a there's a much more
pointed idea that if it works ends the
game immediately it's a maneuver
you pointed it out a little bit earlier
oh wow
oh wow yeah i just completely forgot
about rook a3 wow but if you play rook
a3 immediately then black has what
i guess they take your rook
so the correct move is literally just a
monkey move
what does that mean
it's just like okay i want to play
rookie 3 but i can't because if he takes
f5 so what would uh somebody with no
imagination play
rook f4 yeah that's the best move rook
f4 and black and resigned because this
is unstoppable
that's funny
wow
rook f4 is is like plus 12.
because if black plays queen b8 you can
still play rookie three because you win
the rook in the end
wow
and by the way that is why queen f3 is
better than queen e4 something which you
because in in this line
uh sorry rook f4
um
nurture 7 or
sorry
like for example in this line
the queen is defending d1
and here black has this
oh well
brutal
so rook f4 very simple chess and then
rook a38 is winning but the key to this
position of course is finding king f1
yeah king f1 is nice it kind of
kick-starts
everything
very good but you found that that idea
relatively quickly which is great
you still kind of gave me a hint though
so no hints no it's like don't even talk
to me like i don't you know i have to
figure out everything myself
so
i do have a really nice end game that we
can finish with if you if you're in the
mood for it
yeah let's do it
so we i'll be right back all right i'll
set it up in the meantime so
also hi i've got levi's chat open so
i can finally take over
hope you're enjoying and obviously
this is a like a high-level lesson so i
know some of these positions are hard to
follow you know on my channel there's a
lot of requests for like lessons with
high-rated people and seeing what what
they look like and i think what you're
able to see is that the structure of the
lesson is the same whether i'm teaching
like levy or charlie it's just the
content is different the types of
positions that we do are just totally
different but it's not like we do
anything different we still just solve a
bunch of positions and talk through a
bunch of ideas and principles it's like
the same type of training but i i love i
obviously love teaching really strong
players and you know levy's a captive
audience so it's a lot of fun because he
also appreciates
beautiful ideas and that makes it a lot
of fun to produce examples
it's white to play your goal is to win
this position there is a concrete
solution so it's i think this is really
really lovely and really high level
okay because it's one of those positions
where black is a fortress you have to
break the fortress and
yeah and that's about it
okay that's it
black has fortress and you have to break
fortress i mean okay
exactly i mean okay you have to drive in
the game yeah but okay
my okay it's not taking the bishop and
uh
random moves like bishop d5 probably
lands you in more harm than good so
uh the first thing i looked at was f5
with the idea of bishop c4 fg and i
think that's a winning pawn end game
uh
and uh f5 gf is the only question okay
well it isn't very interesting move yeah
five maybe but okay
yeah i was also like
we just did a whole lesson on why the
hillary like why am i sacking a pawn in
an end game
[Laughter]
which makes me think it might be
something like g4
to prepare the f5 idea
uh
and after g4 bishop g4 bishop f7
i also i'm not sure like king b5 like
yeah king b5
and it's it's unclear what exactly
you've accomplished there you've opened
up the position a little bit but then
you have to go back to c3
yeah exactly
but
you're on the right track right so
you're you've come up with the general
idea of like somehow opening up the king
side but it's unclear how to do it
specifically
yeah where where where two from here
indeed um
maybe it's h4
because normally you don't want to play
h4
because h5
but in that case f5 and bishop e2
excellent so let's consider the move h4
let's go what you're saying is that if
black plays h5 now you play this move
yeah and then you take the h5 pawn and
you win
that's easily winning and what about
bishop f5 in this context i guess um
well you have to you take on f7
and how to assess this position
you just have to it's a king race
so king b5 king d5 king before king d6
king c3 king e5
king yeah d2
really i guess king f6 and you just win
bishop g6
g5 yeah yeah you win the race actually
by only one tempo like king f2 bishop
takes h5 and then you go king f4 yeah
yeah so you would have to calculate the
sequence and then
but you can also win here by the way by
going like king c3 you can you can milk
this a little bit further and then like
bishop e8 so i think there is a way to
do this where you don't even get that
race but the race is also winning
um
so where that leaves us is that h5 loses
yeah what about like h6 or something
well let's you know your default should
always be to ask what if my opponent
does nothing so let's say king c6
yeah yeah yeah
i wonder if we have the same idea to
play h5
h5 uh
so h5 what happens
yeah h5
oh they can maybe take the bishop now or
like okay like h5 okay h5 g takes h5
if we go for that same idea with bishop
e2 then there's just bishop g4 and we're
not going to win that end game right not
to mention maybe even just h4
exactly h4 is very annoying yeah they
just sack and they mirror the pawns yeah
so h5 is my first thing that i would
calculate i'm actually thinking the idea
of g4 is better now than it was like a
move ago somehow but uh i don't i don't
know um alternatively we can play bishop
e2
and just try to advance the pawns and
always go back to c4 if necessary to
break the blockade
and what if h5
maybe back to c4 right and then what's
the next move going to be
king b6 yeah and then f5 and then you
resort to the old idea
yeah yeah so yeah so you're trying to
induce h5 now black again is going to do
nothing king b6 right
now we continue to progress
yeah i guess now g4 g5 should be played
you advance the pawn to g5 i continue
doing nothing this is super important g4
g5
and now h5 should be played and try to
get to h6 probably on there's actually
at this point there's a very
straightforward winning winning idea
ah you don't even have to get the point
this is the beautiful part i think
in fact getting the pawn to h6 oh yeah
it's possible you can get the ponte h6
but you can win without it
straightforward winning idea
now you should consider what move here
you should you should consider the
impact of this move on the position now
that the structure has changed
five
no
no
how did you what did you start with
where was your bishop
no bishop c4 yeah so so you should at
least ask yourself maybe there is some
sort of subtle change in the position
that i'm not accounting for because the
pawn is now on g5 so stare at this
position for a little while
nice there
what yeah anything interesting comes to
mind ah
oh
now f5 because if gf you take take an h5
exactly so your pawns go oh
yeah yeah it's all yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah f5 and a bishop f5 then why is that
easy to win
um bishop f7 you win the h7 pawn and
it's easily winning in game and that's
why you have to put the pawn on g5 for
the audience you you you like no-brainer
g5 dominates three pawns
exactly takes takes bishop g8 bishop
takes him and then h5 will be
unstoppable
yeah yep yep and if gf we can show this
on the board if gf and this is why
you've advanced the pawn to g5 reason
number two you take and go h5 as you
pointed out yeah this is what we wanted
a long time ago but the pawns were here
yeah right right exactly
and that's the winning sequence bishop
e2
either induce h5 or get your pawn to g5
then go back to c4 and then f5 works i
think there's also one more just quick
thing to mention here how this is uh
it's it's it's it's not g6 that wins you
the game it's
h6 that would see the game
because the king
is in the square which is like something
we take for granted but it's actually
you you sack everything and the h1 goes
through for full effect this would be
winning even without the b pawn
yeah it's absolutely brutal
but i guess the b pawn too yeah
what's interesting about that position
is just that you have to how do you
solve that like how do you come up with
this idea
uh it's
it's hard but you have to
kind of do some long-term calculation
and try to understand
how to make specific improvements to
your position so you kind of start by
figuring out that f5 is a possible idea
and then rather than abandoning it when
you realize it doesn't work
you have to try to ask how can i change
the structure on the king side in order
to make f5 work and that's when you
start coming up with the idea of
provoking h5
yeah so which is yeah i i mean i i saw
f5 doesn't quite do it i wanted to go g4
but
that also doesn't make sense and the
flank pawns are
what you really should be using in these
end games so h4h5 right i mean that's uh
that was like my first tactical instinct
but when i was met with some you know
resistance when they didn't do exactly
what i wanted
um
it was kind of frustrating but then but
then bishop e2 back and then g4 g5 and
uh
yeah after that it's i still tried to
force it with h5
so that didn't
uh that didn't cut it you have to go
back to c4 and go for that f5 go for f5
exactly so yeah there's obviously many
more end games we can do but with end
game technique
it seems to me that you struggle with
that a little bit less than
than with middle game technique or is
that or is it or is it both
um
i don't know uh
no i mean my end games aren't
aren't wonderful uh but
i i think that's kind of maybe an
underrated element for me i think
definitely for me it's it's it's much
more
staying focused through that
late opening middle game phase
and then
you know yeah managing my my time at
least in blitz but also in classical i
don't play a lot of classical but
the same thing in classical and just not
getting lost like not drifting just
staying focused constantly and
um
i will frequently like float off into
the ocean
right and spend like 20 minutes and play
a move and it's like absolutely not the
best move and i already spent time and
yeah so
um
i mean my
by far my two strongest points are
dynamics and like prep
like
i mean like i get i get very decent
positions and openings but yeah your
prep is excellent i mean i don't that's
why i don't like playing you because of
the opening yeah like i mean even like i
i i know my stupid lines well i can know
my like uh you know my good lines well
enough um but like beyond that yeah it's
sometimes just pure deer in the
headlights moment like in the in the
middle game and definitely
um forcing dynamics when they're not
there
and uh really missing my opponent's
resources like especially against good
players
like literally like you guys play moves
and i'm like
they could do that
that could be the subject of our next
lesson which i think could be
recognizing your opponent's resources
and how to
how to become a player who
you know who factors in
all of the potential resources and
i think prophylactic thinking can be
developed through like very targeted
training so that could be an interesting
topic as well
yeah i i agree it's it's tough because
the truth is you can't you like they say
you can't play boxing you can't really
play high level chess like you can't i
mean
you literally can play it but i'm just
saying in terms of you can't just do one
lesson every like six months and go okay
well i'm gonna get better at this yeah
it's a ton of targeted training i'm not
doing a whole lot about it so i
i can't be frustrated with my lack of
performance but uh yeah this was a lot
of fun i mean it's good to get
curated
subject matter uh from an esteemed coach
who generally works with people who are
half my age but the same rating
uh do you do that you train like any
talented junior kids yeah yeah i mean
mostly now that's that's mostly all that
i you know all that i do is is you know
i've offloaded some of my students
because i just you people people just
don't always understand how little
little time i have like
yeah i've got like four or five
full-time
things and uh i've mostly kept kept the
talented juniors
yeah that's uh they're fun because
they're really good and their ceiling is
super high and they can make like
moves that you go oh god
wow i don't know that at all right i
don't play in a tournament
yeah
no teaching teaching is the hardest
thing that i do
um like by far actually like one-on-one
teaching because it's like and we've
talked about this in the podcast and
we've talked about this like in private
it's just like the energy demand is so
so high
yep yeah this was uh this was this was
awesome i'll text you hopefully we can
get together soon again i'm down
thanks again levy i'll let you go i'll
uh i'll keep streaming for a couple
minutes but
um i'll let you i'll let you do a
grocery shopping yeah awesome man uh and
yeah have a good lesson at 12. sounds
great my pleasure and uh i'll talk to
you soon
yep take care you too bye
thanks everybody thanks uh people from
levy's stream as well
and uh
i'll see you later
[Music]
you